hello guys and welcome to another
commentary video in this video we have
an update for garden spider-man 4
because apparently according to writer
james vanderbilt the script for director
sam remy spider-man 4 was completely
done before the project was cancelled in
2010 during a screen rant exclusive
interview promoting scream vanderbilt
who worked on the amazing spider-man and
its sequel talked about spider-man 4.
according to the writer the script for
spider-man 4 was completely done before
its cancellation he says here yes so
spider-man 4 we had a full script sort
of ready to go and as it is sort of the
case when you're working a feature
writer they brought in some other great
writers to punch it up they changed some
things and i think about a year later
they got to a point where and i don't
know why but they got to a point where
they decided that wasn't the road they
were going to go down in the years since
spider-man 4 has been abandoned much of
the film's cause narrative has been
revealed picking up where the third
spider-man film left off the movie would
have seen peter and mary jane work
towards reconciling their relationship
while dealing with the death of harry
osborne like the amazing spider-man one
of spider-man 4's villains would have
reportedly been dr kurt connor's the
lizard concept art has also been
revealed that the film would have
featured the classic spider-man
characters such as shocker rhino
mysterio vulture and black cat this
juggling of characters and plot lines
never got to a place where rammy and his
studio were confident they wouldn't
repeat the same mistakes of spider-man
3. spider-man no way home swarm toby
magaya and andrew garfield reprise their
web-slinging roles bringing together
three generations of spider-man it's not
a stretch to say that no way home leaves
the door open for the amazing spider-man
3 and spider-man 4. the film's ending
effectively makes all three spider-man
timelines canon fans could see toby
maguire and andrew garfield's characters
again that being said remy is making his
return to the genre with the upcoming
doctor strange and a multiverse of
madness which is rumored to include a
lot of multiverse characters including
toby maguire's spider-man so there are a
couple things unpacked here one of the
writers for the canceled spider-man 4
said um they brought in some other
riders they changed things and then the
film just ended up not happening so i
wonder if this was some type of studio
intervention so the studio came in
changed some things up and then they
possibly couldn't agree on some story
elements or they wanted to change some
things and parties weren't happy then it
just got cancelled perhaps the studio
just decided that the script wasn't
working or what they wanted to do wasn't
working so then they just cancelled it
and then rebooted the franchise with the
amazing spider-man but they definitely
have a lot of ideas for the fourth
spider-man film but perhaps with
spider-man no way home coming out
they're gonna have to change some things
up if we are going to see a fourth
spider-man film in one of my previous
videos i've actually mentioned some
rumors of a fourth spider-man film being
spoken about behind the scenes and
looking like it could be in production
it's a fingers crossed but um again take
this with a large grain of salt
personally i would love to see the
fourth spider-man film take place after
no way home so we'll see toby maguire
play an older spider-man this does mean
the original script for spider-man 4
probably or most likely cannot be used
perhaps some story elements they can use
and repurpose but they probably would
have to go in a different direction but
as long as sam remy is involved i'll be
happy with whatever they do so tell me
what you guys think in the comment
section below do you wish that we saw
the original spider-man 4 or do you
think it was a good decision that they
canceled spider-man 4 in favor of the
amazing spider-man reboot let me know in
the comment section below and also if
you haven't already please like and
subscribe to show your support and turn
notifications on thanks for watching
guys